Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you. Uh, I pray that you're doing well
and they're not too tired after the storms last night.
Um, but as we get into it today, I once heard
a teacher talk about how she used
to make her students in elementary school walk laps
around the playground at recess.
And one morning, uh, the one girl comes up to her
and reports that another student had cut the corner
while she was walking her laps.
So the teacher invites the other student over
and just calmly asks her, did, did you,
while you were walking your laps earlier,
did, did you cut the corner?
And the girl nervously looked away and said, no.
Now this teacher was an old school,
knew all the tricks, kind of teacher.
And so she asks again this time, added some magical words
to the end of the question.
And she said, did you cut the corner just a little bit?
And for some reason, that gave the girl
vulnerability to share the truth.
And she said, yes, ma'am. Now, why do I share that?
Because I fear that many of us
treat holiness in our lives in the same way.
See, most of us are not pursuing like the big sins,
but all of us are prone
to wander just a little bit.
But this is really important to talk about.
This is really important because you
and me growing in purity
and growing in obedience to God is
what God has for us as his purpose for our lives.
This is his will for us.
This is what first Thessalonians four verse three says,
this is the will of God, your sanctification.
This is what God designed us for, God's purpose,
for your life and for mine is to realign us back
to the perfect standard that Jesus set like He showed us
what a perfect human life looks like.
Yet here's, here's the problem. As we look at a standard
like that, as we look at Jesus being perfect, it,
it prompts a couple questions in our minds.
First of all, like, okay, am I anywhere close to that?
Am I growing towards that?
What does that look like compared to me?
We know that's what we're supposed to be someday.
But, but, but how, how can I even grow into that image
that seems so impossible?
How is it even possible for me in this life?
Well, that's what I hope you see today in God's word.
And so turn back with me to Romans chapter 12.
We're walking through this chapter over the next couple
months, just what does it look like
to live a transformed life in Christ?
Romans 12 specifically verse nine.
Today is where we're going to be Again,
everything in this chapter is a response
to God's great love for us.
Everything in this chapter is, is geared in line with that.
All the commands are are for that gift.
And, and in response to that gift,
that's what this chapter is.
It's reflection in response.
As we looked at verse nine, the first phrase,
let love be genuine last week.
But there's two more phrases here in verse nine.
That's what we're gonna study today.
These two phrases, look at how it continues.
Abhor, what is evil? Hold fast to what is good.
Abhor what is evil? Hold fast to
what is good, God is.
As we look at this, we realize
and acknowledge this is your word.
This is as short as it is, as simple as it may seem.
We know it's not easy
and we know that, that what you're doing
with this is you're wanting to reset our hearts
and draw us to you and lead us in the way of our lasting.
So God, I pray we would all look deeply
as you show us deeply.
If there's any wicked way in us,
and you would lead us in that way everlasting
for your glory, for our good, we would see it and follow it.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So I already said we're gonna talk about holiness today.
What even is holiness like we need
to define the term if we're talking about it today is,
is holiness like mere moral improvement to just kind
of grow in your ability, maybe even moral perfection?
Is that what holiness is?
Or is holiness more of like a, an internal thing
that it it deals with something on the inside?
Yes. Like both it, it's used in scripture both ways.
It indicates a moral quality
that someone is living more like Christ.
That's holiness. It talks about it in that way. Absolutely.
And you can grow in that.
It also talks about just the nature of something
that it is holy.
That's actually the foundation we're gonna set today.
You remember last week if you were here,
we talked about love
and how God's love is the foundation for our love.
We love because he's first loved us.
There's a similar foundation we're setting here today.
It's the fact that God in Christ, if you are in Christ,
he has made you holy like you are holy.
The rest of today we're gonna build off of this,
that if you are in Christ, if you have believed,
like if you have given your heart
and your faith to
Jesus, then you are holy.
Now. We'll, we'll we'll look at the progressive nature
of this a little bit later.
'cause I know some of you're even thinking about this.
Like I'm not holy. Look at
what I did this morning to my kids.
Right? No. So it's not about that yet.
We'll get there right now.
What we're talking about is positional holiness.
Who you are in Christ, who he's made you to be.
This is what we're talking about here.
Remember Romans 12, one, the first verse
of this whole chapter we spent a couple
weeks ago looking at this.
It says, I appeal to you,
therefore brothers, by the mercies of God
to present your bodies as a living sacrifice, holy
and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
We, we looked at that and we said, you already are holy.
So you can know that when you offer yourself,
you're an acceptable sacrifice to God.
So offer so die to self.
Give yourself to the Lord because you already are holy.
It's all over the scriptures though. Titus three verse five.
He saved us not
because of works done by us in righteousness,
but according to his own mercy, by the washing
of regeneration and the renewal of the Holy Spirit.
That means that you are seen as clean now no matter
what you've done, how much you've done, God looks at you,
washed clean by His grace,
his mercy elsewhere.
One Peter two verse nine says that we are now a
holy nation.
Later in Hebrews verse th verse 12 of chapter 13,
Jesus' death it says was to satisfy the people,
sanctify the people through his blood.
Sanctify means to make holy.
His death was to make his people holy.
So again, here's the foundation we will build off of this.
We can't forget this. If you are in Christ,
if you are a believer by faith in Jesus' life, death
and resurrection for you, if that's where your heart aligns,
you stand in that, then spiritually you stand
holy before God.
That is your position and God made you that, right?
This is not, you earned it somehow.
This is not, you did improve morally enough
to be able to stand before God.
Like that. You couldn't. I couldn't.
But God did and made you that for you
because of that.
Then because of that,
when Jesus then says, be holy,
as I am holy, what he means
is live out who you already are.
'cause be holy is passive, right? Like it's, it's a given.
It's a received, you're positionally holy.
So be that like you already are.
Live it out by God's power,
realign your daily lifestyle with your spiritual reality.
This is who you are. So start living it out.
You are positionally in Christ already this, that's
what Romans one through 11 says.
By the way, it defends
that you are positionally in Christ there.
Then practically work that out more every day.
That's Romans 12 through 16, right?
Positionally, you are this. So practically work this out.
Specifically chapter 12 gives us the character that we need
to have specifically here today.
Verse nine. This is how you do that.
How do you live out that you're already holy?
What does that look like day to day?
What did he say first here again as a response
to already be made holy.
What does he say abhor, what is evil?
How do we do? How do we live it out?
How do we live off the foundation of holiness?
We abhor what is evil? What is rotten?
What doesn't line up with the character of God?
That's that word evil.
Now, I know that word abhor is one
that we don't use very often, first of all
'cause it's hard to say doesn't
roll off the tongue very easily.
But, but can we agree that it just sounds terrible,
doesn't it right to abhor something like it just,
it just really makes you feel bad.
And we often use the word hate here instead,
but let's not miss the nuance.
Why did God's word pick this word?
Because the word abhor brings with it the idea
of having a visceral reaction to something you dislike
so much so that you avoid it.
When I was a kid, my mom paid me $5
to try a little piece of tomato.
And let's just say I had a visceral reaction to it.
My gag reflex hit really hard. And so what do I do now?
I avoid tomatoes. It's just the reality of it.
I, I had such a dislike that my body reacted to it
and so now I avoid them completely.
I know that's kind of silly compared to this, but,
but that's the idea of abhorring something is that you,
you strongly do not just like I kind of dislike it,
but so strongly hate abhor it,
that that's how you react.
I love how the apostle Paul explained this more deeply over
in Ephesians chapter five, verses three through 12.
Just listen to with that idea of hor, of abhorring hating
what is evil, listen to
how he says it here in Ephesians five, sexual immorality
and all impurity
or covetousness must not even be named among you
as is proper among saints.
Let there be no filthiness nor foolish talk
nor crude joking, which are out of place.
But instead, let there be thanksgiving for you may be sure
of this, that everyone who is sexually immoral or impure
or who is covetous, that is an idolater,
has no inheritance in the kingdom of Christ.
And God let no one deceive you
with empty words for because of these things.
The wrath of God comes upon the sons of disobedience.
Therefore, do not become partners with them.
For at one time you were darkness,
but now you are light in the Lord.
Walk as children of light.
For the fruit of light is found in all that is good
and right and true
and try to discern what is pleasing to the Lord.
Now listen to this verse 11, take no part
in the unfruitful works of darkness,
but instead expose them for it is shameful even to speak
of the things that they do in secret, right?
That's pretty clear, isn't it?
It says that Christians, we, we should hate evil so much
that we avoid it, that we should be
known for how much we don't even consider being a part
of those kinds of things like sexual morality, greed,
crude joking that we revile it so much
that we avoid it all together.
Why? Because those are examples of dark things
and we aren't in darkness anymore.
What does it say? He's made us light in the Lord.
So if we're light not in darkness, we walk
as if we are in the light.
Now we walk as children of light. So we don't participate.
We don't even want to participate
in the things of the darkness.
That's why the searching question
that I asked myself all week in,
in light of all of this, just like that teacher at recess,
the searching question I asked was,
how am I compromising just a little bit?
How am I compromising just a little bit?
I know how to avoid the big stuff, but,
but just a little bit meaning like instead of hating
any evil that still remains in my heart,
I'm pretty content to let it simmer.
Let it fester in there,
dabble in it a little bit here and there.
Like how, how am I
compromising just a little bit?
Like I know I'm positionally holy in Christ,
but how am I not living that out
progressively in my daily life?
I'm just content to stay where I'm at.
What, why am I doing it that way?
See, listen, if I, if we were having a personal conversation
and I asked you, have you, have you compromised your faith?
I mean most of us would say pretty strongly, quickly, no,
no, I'm a believer.
I know I'm going to heaven when I die.
I know I have a relationship with God.
I'm forgiven of my sins. I haven't compromised my faith.
But if I asked you, have you compromised just a little bit,
would that change your answer?
Like if you just sat on that question,
maybe you'd write this down and do this later.
If you, if you just sit on that question for a,
a few quiet moments,
and we'll do this again a little bit later, but,
but if you just sat there and reflected
and asked God, a whole lot would rise
to the sur surface, wouldn't it?
If we're honest,
if we just take Matthew five through seven,
Jesus famous sermon on the Mount
and just read through that, prayerfully asking, God, show me
any wicked way in me, don't you think
there'd be quite a few things start
to get exposed in our hearts that we just let slide
and then slip through and, and motives that are bad
and, and we see all that.
We start to let that rise to the surface.
It's there
like again, I saw it in myself this week.
I know I fear, I, I know that I do this,
but I fear that we
allow a lot more in our lives than we're readily
willing to admit.
Like I fear that we don't hate sin as much as we say we do.
See, here's what we're doing humans.
We, we are so prone to set the standard from the bottom up.
And so what we're doing is we're comparing ourselves
to a murderer or to an adulterer or to Hitler
or whatever, and we, we look at that,
we're like, man, we're okay.
I'm not as bad as they are.
Look, I'm, I'm closer
to straight vertical than they are like I I get.
But when we look to Jesus and,
and we, we see then how far from vertical
that we really actually are,
how much we allow in our lives, it's not of God.
If we really just align ourselves and, and,
and examine ourselves according to his standard,
we are so far off.
So then the question is what do we do with that?
Like what should we do then?
Well, what, what did Romans 12 say to do?
Abhor? What is evil?
Like when we see how far off we
are, what do we do with that?
We recommit to hating our sin like
God hates our sin.
And I'm talking about all of it,
not just the big ones but all of it.
Not just the actions
but even the thoughts behind the actions.
Like that's what Sermon on the Mount is so powerful to do.
When Jesus talked about, he didn't just talk about actions,
he talked about the motivations behind the actions.
He talked about the reason you do fill in the blank.
That's even what we must hate
and we have to recommit to this.
We have to, we have to crush the lust in our hearts
that causes us to take a second glance at that woman.
We have to die to the desire for a greater reputation
that causes us to lie to people,
to make ourselves look better.
Like we have to cut off that relationship
that is stirring up thoughts of gossip
and bullying in your life.
Cut it off. And again,
we've gotta be active in this
because like John Owens said about 500 years ago, he said,
you've got to be killing sin or it will be killing you.
This is a war, right?
We can't just sit back and say, well it will be fine.
No, in God's power, we have to commit to put sin to death,
to kill it in our lives, to hate it.
Not just try to manage it, not just try to tame it,
not put it in the closet, stuff it back there
so nobody sees it or that we hope it doesn't destroy us.
No, we can't do that. We must kill it.
Even if it costs us financially
or professionally or socially,
it might cost something
but we must kill it.
And listen, I say that strongly, which only makes me
that much more grateful
for the foundation that we started with.
Remember, Christ already overcame sin.
Christ has made you holy
by winning that battle over sin.
Like so Christ has defeated the sin that we wrestle with,
the sin that we struggle with, the evil that surround us.
He's already overcome it. He has already made us holy.
And so what that means is the foundation must supersede
what we've been talking about, how hard it is to do this.
The foundation is that you can
by God's power live out this reality
that you already are holy in Christ.
It's possible. I know it may seem impossible
to overcome sin, to hate sin, yes,
but in Christ it is possible
because he's already got the victory over it.
So take heart in that, right? Be grateful for that.
When we saw Romans 12, nine, the rest of it there was,
there was actually another imperative there, right?
That last phrase of the verse, what did it say?
Hold fast to what is good
Abhor, what is evil?
Hold fast to what is good.
It's like the other end of the spectrum, right?
It's almost like these are counterweights.
That the way you abhor evil is by clinging more to
what is good, to what aligns with God's character, to
what he sees as good.
It's like they go together.
The more you do one, the less you do the other one, right?
So they go together in this
and in the original language, that word
for hold fast is actually the idea
of gluing things together, cementing together
to join or fasten firmly together.
It's the same word you might have heard at a wedding
sometime ago, Genesis 2 24, all the way back
before the fall of man.
He says, therefore a man shall leave his father
and his mother and hold fast to his wife
and they shall become one flesh.
That concept is all over God's word.
A husband, husband and wife become one.
They are distinct,
but they are intimately joined together
as if they are one entity.
Beautiful picture of the gospel.
Romans 12, nine says that we are to be
that with what is good.
Hold fast. Cement yourself to what is good.
So much so that it's like you are one with it.
Here's the problem though, I don't always
do that very well.
I don't, I don't hold fast to things
that are good 100% of the time.
Like I hold fast to myself a lot.
I hold fast to my phone a lot.
I hold fast to the things
of the world a lot more than I hold fast to the things
that are good at times in my life.
And so this is reality.
Like we don't always hold fast to what is good.
And the the reality, the the truth is if we're fair,
if we measure ourselves according to Christ's standard,
we will always feel a little bit discouraged by
how far we are off of that.
So here's the wrestling we have to do.
How do we then avoid hopelessness?
We're supposed to to align ourselves.
We're supposed to be like Christ.
But we're so far from that.
How can we not get hopeless in that struggle?
Think about an oak tree.
I read one author asked the question, how did
that tree start?
Well, with just an acorn, right?
Like some absent-minded squirrel dropped it somewhere
and it gets pressed into the soil.
As it gets pressed into the soil, it begins to germinate
and roots form, which led
to a stem growing upward, which led to branches emerging,
which led to then a few leaves coming off of those branches.
But but notice That's an oak tree, right?
It's just in miniature form. That is an oak tree.
It's not a future oak tree that is an oak tree.
Yet you know why God planted that acorn?
Because he intended for a mighty oak.
Because in that half ounce acorn is the potential
for a 30 ton oak tree that spreads its branches wide,
providing shade, providing food for animals, all
of those things.
And over time that little sapling with the right process
will eventually mature
and grow into that 30 ton oak tree.
Same thing in us over time
with God's process, his work in us, we will grow,
we will mature into that strong tree like that
where our, our daily lives begin
to match more like our positional
reality over time.
That happens where,
where you just have at the beginning you have a glimmer
of hope that grows into a full fledged life-giving joy
that lasts through whatever comes your way.
You, you see that you start by just tolerating people
and that grows over time to where you begin
to actually love your enemies.
You have really flaky self-control early in life.
But as you grow into that, it becomes this deep moral
goodness that everybody can see.
That's growth.
And so yes, we need to realize that,
that we don't measure up to Christ's perfect standard.
But here's the question.
Let's start measuring success a little bit differently
by this question.
Like the teacher with the student this time though,
how am I growing?
Just a little bit. We know we don't measure
up, But let the question be this.
How am I actually just growing a little bit?
Because remember that tiny sapling
is an oak tree, right?
We're not saying anything that you have to earn your
salvation or or prove yourself to be sick.
No, that is an oak tree.
And if there are even just buds of leaves on the branches,
that tree is bearing fruit, right?
It's alive, it's bearing fruit. It just looks tiny.
It's a bud right? Now it's not a full fledged like you have
an apple tree that hasn't butted out yet.
It's not full of apples yet. But is there growth happening?
That's the question. It's not whether it looks perfect
or not yet it's is the growth occurring?
So think about your life. Are you
further along in your faith than you were a year ago?
Am I more Christlike today than I was at the age of 25?
And listen, I, I realize
and fully acknowledge regularly to you and to my wife
and to my kids and to everyone.
I'm not perfect yet, but praise God, I'm not where I was.
Can't we can't we realize that we get discouraged
'cause we don't measure up perfectly yet, but,
but look at what God has done.
Look at how he's grown.
You look at how he's moved in your life.
And so that's the question. Are you growing
even in baby step kind of ways?
Are you growing? Do you see the fruit
of the spirit coming out more regularly in your life?
Do you see the Holy Spirit working in you
to grow in your ability to hate what is evil
and clinging to what is good?
Do you see that growing more
as you look over the long period of time?
Now here's the thing about all this, just as true
for you as it is for me.
We come in here every Sunday,
we come in here Wednesday nights,
we do other things at other times with other groups
and we rejoice and sing
and praise God for what he's done to make us
positionally holy before God.
He's justified us, meaning made right with God.
He's made us holy one day He's coming back to take us home.
All that we, we rejoice in the fact
that we will be with him forever.
And that's positional and we rightly rejoice in that.
But progressive holiness here is hard.
Positional holiness is, it's not easy, but it's simple.
It's because of Christ. Praise God for that.
Progressive holiness today is hard
because for the rest of our lives, whether you're old
or whether you're young, for the rest
of our lives there will be a tension between the good
and the evil inside us and around us.
There's always this reality
that there will be times in our lives.
The counterweights don't always go the right way
and there'll be times we grow more than we do at other times
in our lives that will grow less at some times than
other parts of our lives.
The track of holiness in your life is not zero to a hundred
and it's a perfectly vertical like straight
line between the two.
It often looks a whole lot more like this
as you grow in your life.
But the trend is towards holiness.
It just might mean in this week, this month,
this day it's a little bit struggle.
But eventually God grows you and you keep growing over time.
That's the reality.
There will be times that we make more progress.
It's hard, it's a struggle.
But listen, that's not a new problem.
It's not unique to you.
You and I are not the first people to have dealt
with this reality.
We're not facing something that has not been faced before.
Listen to the Apostle Paul,
who the greatest missionary in the world has ever known.
Listen to what he says. Romans 7 21 through 24.
He says, I find it a law that when I want to do right,
evil lies close at hand.
For I delight in my, in the law of God, in my inner being
I want to, but I see in my members the body another law
waging war against the law of my mind
and making me captive to the law of sin
that dwells in my members, wretched man that I am
who will deliver me from this body of death.
Like that's strangely encouraging to me.
This is Paul, like the the great Paul.
And he's saying, man, I'm struggling.
It's hard Because he's honest.
Progressive sanctification is hard. It's a struggle.
It's a constant battle. So how do we fight it?
If we could give up, how do we fight?
Let's remember our foundation today, right?
Remember who you are, Christian, like this is first.
Remember that because Jesus was sinless, that
by his death he has made you holy as well.
I guess what he did, he's made you that.
It's not that you could earn it.
He's given you a new nature, a new identity.
One that naturally recoils from
what doesn't match his character.
He's made you different.
You are different in him.
And then driven by that grace,
we are then to give every effort to grow in our hatred
of evil pursuing godliness.
That's then what we do in response to his grace.
Okay? So how do we do that? Well, don't overcomplicate this.
Let me just give you a simple way to think about this.
How do I grow in this ability to hate what was evil
and and clinging to what is good?
How do I do that? Lemme just give you a simple way.
Think about the things you do in life.
Think about pursue, watch, whatever.
If we wanna grow in this, just do less of the things
that steal your affections from Christ
and do more of the things that stir your affections
for Christ, right?
Think about that. Do less of the things
that steal your heart
and your affections away from the Lord.
Whatever that is in your life. Maybe it's video games
or maybe it's this person in your relationship
or maybe it's lust
or maybe it's greed or maybe it's whatever else.
And like I pursue it that way. Do less of that stuff.
'cause what that does is steals you
heart away from the Lord.
Do less of that, but do more
of the things that stir your affections for Jesus.
The things that are going to increase your love,
that stir your heart to follow him.
More. Like worship together with your brothers
and sisters, reading his word and discovering who Christ is.
You're seeing man this time with my kids or
or nature in this way.
Those are things that stir my affections for Jesus.
And so I wanna do more of that and do less of other stuff.
Don't overcomplicate this.
Just think about everything you do,
everything you think about, everything you want to do
and say, does that stir my affection for Jesus
or steal it away
and then make a decision based on that.
But again, don't forget that this desire to hate evil
and submit yourself to what is good.
Romans seven said it's gonna be a struggle at times.
It will be a struggle.
And so you have to make a decision at times.
I have to make a decision at times.
Am I going to obey God even when it's hard?
That's why we can't forget this truth.
Deuteronomy 10 13 says this, that that all that God commands
for us is for our good.
See, God's not up there as a cosmic killjoy just
saying, you can't have any fun.
I just want you to follow all the rules.
That's not what God's like God is saying, I designed life
to work the best way this way.
If you wanna flourish, here's how you live your life.
And so we follow that. We obey that.
That's where life is actually the best.
And so he's not trying
to keep us down When we hold what's good
and we eliminate what's evil, we align with his character
that's gonna be good for us.
But I'm not gonna get to do what they do.
I'm not gonna get to experience that He's got what's better
for you if you just listen and obey.
He will lead you towards the goodness of it.
So those are ways we fight. Those are ways we fight.
Stay in it because there's one more way.
We fight through this tension we feel daily in our lives.
And this may be one of the most important reasons.
Do you remember, remember how Romans 7 24 ended?
I just read it a second ago.
He, he said, wretched man that I am
who will deliver me from this body of death.
You feel that one, right? Like some of you feel that.
I feel that in my soul.
Like go man, I'm time's
wretched God, just get me outta here.
Like I'm ready for this to be done. Get outta here.
I I just wanna be gone.
That is not the cry of a desperate man.
When Paul says that that is
a cry that's actually full of hope
because he's not asking that
because he doesn't know the answer.
He's asking that rhetorically to set up what he's about
to say in verse 25.
Who's gonna deliver me Verse 25.
Thanks be to God through Jesus Christ our Lord.
He knew the answer. He just like, God,
I wanna cry this out to you.
Thanks be to God that you are going
to deliver me that believer.
That is our ability to stand firm today.
It hinges on the fact that we have a God who's
with us in the battle, who has already won the battle
and is one day coming back to deliver us from all the evil
that we battle every day.
The evil inside us, the evil around us one day is coming.
He's going to deliver us.
That's what makes it easier today to hate what is evil,
to cling to what is good.
Because we know that some days coming, we won't have
to struggle anymore.
That's what I love about Philippians one, six.
Yeah, one of my favorite verses is Philippians one, six.
I am sure of this, that he
who began a good work in you will bring it
to completion at the day of Jesus Christ.
He started the sanctification,
the holiness work in you when you believed.
But he's working it all out to bring it
to completion at the day of Jesus Christ.
He's realigning you even today towards that standard.
But one day's coming when we'll be fully aligned to it.
And so what do we do until then?
We lay aside every weight
and sin that so easily entangles us
and we run with endurance the race
that is marked out for us.
Fixing our eyes on our prize.
Jesus, He's the finish line.
He just brings this full holiness with him when he comes.
That's our hope. So let me invite you
to close your eyes with me for a moment.
I said, we're gonna do this
before to just take these questions
and reflect on them for a few moments here.
If you've ever wondered whether God would answer prayer,
this is one he will make very clear.
When you ask God, search me
and see if there's any wicked way in me, he will show you.
And so that question of am I compromising just a little bit?
Ask yourself that and
and just don't, don't run to the love
of God and the forgiveness of God too quickly.
Sit in this because we are so prone to self-deception.
And so sit in this
and just say, God, where am I
compromising Just a little bit.
Where am I allowing things in my life that are not of you?
Where am I just being content and
and satisfied to have all this junk in there?
Why God show me
and God give me a hatred, a holy hatred of it.
So much so that I avoid it.
And Lord, I pray that as we reflect on that, as
as you spend the next few minutes and hours and days
and weeks and and we're that that pebble is in our shoe
and we can't get away from it of
how we're compromising just a little bit.
Lord, that you in that also draw us back to your love
and how you have already forgiven us,
already made us holy positionally in Christ
that we can't sin too much.
But Lord, I pray that we would so be transformed,
that we would grow in hating sin more,
that we would grow in our obedience
to you more we would grow as we look to you
and submit to your work in our lives,
that we look more like Jesus tomorrow than we did today.
At five years from now, we'd look back
and say, wow, God, what you've done
yet, looking forward to the day you return
and finish the work.
Lord, give us strength. May everyone in this room,
everyone watching online, may we all have a renewed sense
of your victory over sin
and your gift of the ability for us to walk that out today.
You'd free people from the chains
of darkness to walk in the light.
God, do that. Do that among us. It's not us, God, it's you.
So may we worship you now. In Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Let's stand together.